[MUSIC]
Hi, today we'll talk about wine-making,
but not really
about the technology of wine-making or
how to choose a good bottle of wine --
something that I know little about.
Instead, we'll talk about
the genetic basis of wine making.
Humans figured out how to make
wine thousands of years ago, but
with all due respect the biggest star
of winemaking is not Robert Mondavi.
The biggest star of winemaking is yeast.
However, until recently, it
was not clear how yeast
accomplished the very complex
process of wine making.
And today we will learn
how clustering algorithms
help scientists to figure
out how yeast made wine.
I'll start with the question:
Which domesticated animal
is missing in this slide?
And of course you already know the answer
since the whole lecture is about yeast.
It is yeast.
In fact, ten years ago, scientists
found an Armenian cave
equipped with old wine making
equipment including
even stone cups for wine drinking.
And my next question is: Why do we store
grapes in sealed containers to make wine?
It doesn't appear to be necessary
because yeasts live on grapes,
and they have natural abilities to
transform glucose in grapes into ethanol.
And therefore, it looks like the only
thing that is needed to make wine
is simply to crush grapes and
let yeast do their job.
However, it's not that easy.
It turns out that yeast have
developed another amazing ability.
After they transform glucose into ethanol
and run out of glucose,
they can invert their metabolism and
feed on the ethanol they just produced.
And thus, they would ruin the wine
that they just made.
And this change - reversion of metabolism-
is called the diauxic shift.
And our goal today
is to figure out which yeast genes
are implicated in the diauxic shift.
But before we answer this question,
I wanted to ask you: What does it take,
biochemically, to convert
glucose into ethanol?
Imagine the time,
over 100 million years ago,
when the first fruit bearing
plants appeared on earth.
At that time,
an organism that would invent a way to
metabolize glucose in fruit would
have an enormous evolutionary benefit,
particularly if it would
convert glucose into ethanol,
because ethanol is a poison for
most of the competitor of the organism.
However, transforming glucose
into ethanol is not a small feat,
let alone metabolizing
ethanol afterwards.
It is very complex by
chemical reaction and
it requires creating
new metabolic pathways.
Essentially, a revolution in the
biochemical abilities of the organism.
We know that genes mutate and
can build new functions, but
in this case, developing one, two,
three, even ten genes here and
there, won't accomplish the task of
building a new metabolic pathway.
Let's create a certain
evolutionary puzzle and
we'll return back to Susumu Ohno,
who's work we started in the
Genome Rearrangement chapter.
Susumu Ohno came up with
the Random Breakage Model,
that has become the dogma of
chromosome evolution study for 30 years,
until it was refuted just 10 years ago.
So why do you bring Susumu Ohno
if his random breakage
model turned out to be wrong?
Because he came up with another evolutionary
model that had a very different fate.
He argued that big leaps
in evolution would not
have been possible without
whole genome duplication.
Essentially, doubling the number of
chromosomes in the genome and thus
doubling the number of genes.
And whole genome duplication, in difference to
the Random Breakage Model, first was
heavily criticized by biologists.
They did not believe in it for 30 years,
until it was confirmed just ten
years ago, roughly at the same time as
when the Random Breakage Model
was confirmed.
But how does whole genome duplication help
to invent new metabolic pathways?
Well, right after the whole
genome duplication,
every gene will be present in two copies.
One copy will be free to evolve whatever
new revolutionary function is needed.
For example,
creating a new metabolic pathway,
while another copy of the gene
will simply support the life of
the existing organism; do whatever function that
it was supposed to do before the duplication.
So, after we introduce the biological
background for the diauxic shift,
our next goal is to explain how biologists
measure gene expression
to study the diauxic shift.